And it was using the bodybuilding industry for a long time because when you
inject it,
it gives you,
uh,
like this amazing Tan and they call it tad stimulates your melanin on that
fucking show that was turning black.
She believed that she was,
yeah.
Then the wrong skin.
So she was shooting something and do her body and she got black like Congo
black.
Well,
I,
I tried it out.
I tried it out for about a week.
You tried to get black?
No,
I didn't try to get black.
Just wants us,
wanted to see what happened to the Tan.
I started to get some freckles.
But the side effect of this is you get massive boners that last a really
annoyingly long time.
So you can't say no,
but people will use,
this is like almost light,
like a,
an Ed type of drug.
But it,
and I don't even know the mechanism of action.
Like I don't know how it's even working.
Well,
it's giving you a black,
so basically you get it.
Yeah.
You get a Tan and boners.
I don't know.
That's not how you would administer millennial talent.
She's,
she's doing some kind of like a volume.
What is that thing that she's doing with the syringe?
What?
That looks like a caulking gun.
Like what is she doing?
Picture.
I don't know.
Yeah,
that bitch isn't another type of thing.
Like the Kardashians are doing to their ass cheeks like fillers.
I don't know what they're doing throughout ass there.
They're doing something that seems like,
well,
it's very popular with the young people these days.
They're taking fat out a certain parts of their body and putting it in their
ass.
Right.
It's not,
I don't,
well let's,
we should find out what is he getting diaper.
But just Google.
How are women today?
How are Instagram models getting diaper?
But I'm curious because that's what it is.
It's what you're using their own.
So they're taking their fat from somewhere else on their body.
Yes.
Injecting.
I know that some people do that.
We should do that.
Cabs that way we could start an Instagram calf channel.
No,
I don't want fat calves.
Will the jiggling walk like a girl's butt while he's pulling that up?
What kind of coffee is this?
Uh,
this is black rifle coffee.
It's good.
Yeah,
it's good stuff.
Yeah.
I figured out something.
Thank you by the way,
for hooking me up with trigger.
Oh,
that's great.
Right.
I will just trigger Timberline's.
So those are the Shit I've been making a coffee rub for the style coffee rub
before.
Yes.
I have trigger has her own coffee rub you well they have their own I love you
trigger but that I sometimes never know what all is in some of these spices and
rubs.
You know,
they'll add some time,
you know,
Maltodextrin and show her and stuff.
Yeah,
there's some sugar in there.
So I find grind,
grind,
grind coffee and I mixed that with black cone assault,
Cayenne pepper and Paprika.
And you can just make that rub his thick as you want.
Put that on the Ribeye.
And I've almost switched completely from doing my,
my stove top sear followed by the quick broil on either side to do in like a one
and a half to two hour smoke in the trigger with that coffee rub on.
And they're just finishing it on the grill with the tracker.
Yeah,
I did a uh,
uh,
what,
what would you call it?
A prime rib,
you know,
like,
so instead of eat,
it's basically ribeye roast and I did one on the trigger and I cooked it for
like four hours at 220 degrees.
Holy Shit.
You smoked it four hours.
Yes,
yes.
And that it had,
I used the traders scrub smoke at that temperature.
This is a super smoke setting at two 25 and below press the super smoke button
and it constantly infuses this pump of smoke.
Like,
like it's like,
whoa.
I've never tried super smoke at that high of a temperature.
Good delicious dude.
And the,
but the Trager prime rib rub,
I know it has sugar in it.
It's taste too delicious to not,
but holy Shit,
when it's in there for three and a half,
four hours and it has that crossed on it.
There's some lord some about that long smoke.
Have you tried to beer?
Can chicken beer can chicken?
I've,
I've tried a bunch of different rubs on that,
but just,
just core salt and black pepper works fine for the beer.
Can Chicken.
Yeah.
Empty about half of the beer can you open up the beer can,
but then you poke a couple extra holes in the top so you get more of the steam
so they inside of the chicken gets even more moist.
But then when I figured out is if you use like a little little scalpel or exacto
knife and you cut open the skin of the chicken around the outside a little bit
and you stuff that with pads of butter and then you do your smoke pads of butter
and said the chicken that the skin gets crispy,
like super crispy.
And so you just,
it's like,
I think it's like an hour,
an hour and a half.
He Cook that one and he can't,
you can't smoke that one very successful.
Like you want to run the grill with the smoke on but you can't super smoke.
It didn't seem to work so well,
but that beer can chicken.
That's fricken amazing.
Whoever figured that out,
whatever drunk figured that out as the God damn genius do.
It works.
But I've wondered before,
if there are other things that will work even better than beer.
We've got Jamie,
it says in most cases what I'm finding is either Brazilian butt lift or just
like a fat graft or fat injection.
But there have been cases where I'm seeing that they had to get an injection
taken out within weeks because it was causing a problem.
So like I don't know if that was just fat,
but you got the fat put in then you have to get a take it back out.
Yeah cause they were gonna they were dying.
It'd be a bummer.
Great.
And then you have this fucking war zone of an APP.
Most of that is like leaves,
some barks,
a Syrian few POCs.
Airstrip.
Yeah.
No more.
G string,
32 people died supposedly in 2017 from wonderful.
Yeah.
That's like the same amount of people that died from coconuts falling on their
head.
That's a fucking ridiculous way to die.
You know?
And here's the thing,
the,
what they're doing is not aesthetically pleasing because it violates your
sensibilities.
Cause you look at the ass and you look at the legs and you go,
what's wrong here?
How did you get that ass with those legs?
They don't go together.
Like if you look at like a cross fitters legs,
like one of them powerful gals with a big butt,
but they also have to see with those high neon compression socks.
Ooh,
la La.
It looks right.
It fits.
Like if the ass fits the thigh,
it's not entirely disproportionate when the ass pumps out and then he goes to
these little toothpick legs.
He like,
that's gross.
That's weird.
You know,
like it's comparable.
That's a real ass.
That's a real Instagram.
We may be evolving as a species to find these type of things.
More attractive though,
because that's the whole idea was social media is you get a dopamine hit every
time you click on the little blue notification button or you look at a new
photo.
So maybe we're just going to eventually develop a real appreciation for that
type of symmetry.
No,
we'll redefine.
All right.
Know what true human symmetry is incorrect.
It doesn't look as good.
It just doesn't look as good.
It's a,
it's a cheap fix your squats.
Yeah.
Get your ass to the gym.
Girls.
To some dead lifts.